List of things that men love hearing part 2
No. 6 “thank you for always listening to my drama”
we all know that men don't care to talk about every little detail
throughout their day so when you have a man that would gladly listen to you
thank him and appreciate him
and honestly marry him
7 “wow, you look so buff today”
even if he's not built like a bodybuilder
he's likely to appreciate the sentiment
or if he's been putting extra work in the gym and he's starting to see progress
never neglect to notice the progress that he's making
No. 8 “I love your haircut”
it's not just women who like this compliment
men love it too
so if he has a fresh cut make sure to acknowledge it and
tell him that he looks good